people are gonna love this
but you're
um you have a long history of
persevering through
injuries
through insane amounts of injuries
my ability to tolerate pain is probably
more than most people
but see injuries aren't just pain right
it's like um it's also mental like
psychological like again like the weight
cut it can make a lot of people quit yep
can you
tell your history of injuries
what are the biggest injuries the
toughest injuries in your career
um
starting from
what your early teens my early teens um
i actually got out of sports
from 11 to
i say like 15 years old 16 years old
because
a kid shot a double leg through my
kneecap and i partially tore all the
ligaments in my knee cartilage meniscus
the whole nine yards
and i had to learn how to walk again i
spent two years in a leg brace crutches
you know hobbling around the schoolyard
that one was a challenge to come back
from um
i've broken
most of my ribs
i won nationals with nine broken ribs
i was actually getting
novocaine shots into my chest to avoid
feeling the pain
and then wrapping them to try to
make sure i didn't pop along
i've broken my collarbone
i have five herniated discs in my neck
i fractured my back twice
i've broken my tailbone i tore my s i
joints
i've torn my right hamstring twice my
left one once
um
[Music]
broken my ankles a few times i spun it
once in a 360 that had death surgery
fingers toes elbows shoulders
so all of these are first of all
you're uh
you're tough
you're tough dude man
so each of those have a story behind
them
so if you're talking about the
collarbone
or the ankles
uh or or the back the neck
is there interesting stories here that
are behind these injuries heart training
heart competing
jiu jitsu judo
on so ground stuff like
uh sparring in the dojo or like drilling
or all that kind of stuff is
if you were to sort of break it down
your understanding of this the landscape
of injuries you went through
i've never had one in jiu jitsu
ever
i mean i might have like torn a
fingernail or like
you know gotten key burn but i've never
been like
seriously injured i know when ponza
straight ankle locked me at copapodio
that
hurt but i wasn't injured like it felt
sore
but like if i had to run like i could
run
i can now understand probably exactly
where the injuries came from then
you're very quickly excelled to jiu
jitsu
you have achieved another level in judo
and i think that means
the intensity with which you approach
judo
to achieve that world-class level
probably is the source of the injuries
yeah because
the mentality
of how i
approached judo versus jiu jitsu
jiu jitsu to me is like
a game that like we would play like if
you wanted to like grab a basketball and
like go play a game of one-on-one that's
like jiu-jitsu to me like i can't take
the sport in its entirety seriously
because i feel like the community of jiu
jitsu doesn't take it seriously
you